Okay, does anybody else feel like music has gotten so depressing lately?
What is with all of these sad,
like, vibey,
slow, emotional song?
I have nothing against Taylor Swift,
but I tried listening to her newest album.
I was like, two or three songs in, and I was like,
I need to get up,
I need to go outside.
I need to, like,
shake off this, like, feeling.
It was just, like,
depressing and, like,
I get it. Sometimes you need a good,
like, sad song, right?
You need a song you can feel and you can, like,
relate to, and it needs to have deep lyrics and.
And those songs are great,
but those songs shouldn't be every song.
Our society needs to pump it up right now.
We need some new music.
We need some fun music.
Where is the Pitbull?
Where's the Jason Derulo?
Where are, like,
the stupid, fun summertime songs?
Where are they?
And on a serious note,
I think it's really important to pay attention
to the type of music you listen to.
And I think sometimes
we overlook how big of a role the media we consume
affects us and affects our emotions
and affects our well being.
We need to get some fun music up in here.
Our society needs some fun.
We are too emotional.